小哥
我们现在难度越来越高了
所以我们今天要用行动艺术
来呈现今天的主题
3 2 1 开始
我刚前面已经表演过了
小哥今天很没精神
我们在放空
在放空
我們在放空
我最喜歡放空
你最喜歡放空
到底是哪個放空
你知道全世界有發呆放空比賽嗎
有這種比賽啊
對啊 你去參加你一定第一名的啊
你天天放空
放空也會被嘎的時候啊
什麼叫放空被嘎
就是醒醒啊醒醒啊醒醒啊醒來啊你
這樣子
對醒醒好不好
因為我們今天錄完這一集
我們還要再加入Podcast
逸於三吃
小哥來把你
剛剛才錄你才答案秀
逸於三吃明明就古魚啊
這樣子啊
魚頭粵魚身
小哥來就這樣
吃乾麻醉
要宣傳一下啦
趙華語古惑仔
真的
你是第一集的開國元老
對啊
我第一集來錄之後就第一名
現在落到第一集了
12、3名了吧
12、3名了
誇要輸老王了
我目前還暫時贏老王
希望粉絲們定起來
定起來啦
追蹤起來
定起來
趙華語古惑仔Podcast
今天要來教什麼呢
來揭秘了
好
我們要歡迎收看理財達人秀的
《歌有仇必報》
我們現在是第二季喔
小哥拖了很久才錄第二季喔
所以我們的難易度有時候起起伏伏
今天教的有點難又不會太難
我們要教大家什麼叫做放空
什麼叫做融券
因為每一次我們在理財達人秀裡面
會說我們要放空避險
如果你看這個線型壞掉走空投
你可以放空
就會好多人來留言說
什麼是放空
我只會買股票做多啊
放空到底什麼意思
今天好不好全解析
讓你理解放空可以怎麼做
如果大盤高檔走空
放空利潤也是很驚人的
不過真的好多人
什麼是融券什麼是放空
完全不懂
反向思考就很困難
趙老你有新手機嘛 對啊
手機借我一年可以嗎 什麼
誰理你 借你可以要費用
因為你現在手機裡去買要帶要4萬
一年後可能是要3萬 對
所以你假如知道說它一年後
股價一定會跌的話 對
就像我們講的 手機一年後一定跌的啦 對
我先跟你借
借一年後 借你 然後呢
一年後再還你 要還我囉
你就買一台3萬的 對
我跟你借的時候我先拿去賣掉
哎唷
因為現在市場上這個還不容易
那麼買
很快買得到嘛
對
我先把它賣掉
好賣到四萬塊錢
賣到四萬塊
嗯
那一年後呢
我的手機呢
我在市場上買全新的給你
哎唷也是新的啊
全新的嗎
一樣的啊
那時候只剩三萬塊嘛
哎唷
那我就賺到價差一萬塊啦
耗力一萬
對對對
那這個叫做放空啦
就叫放空
就要融券
對
那我们刚刚讲的是物品嘛
那股票呢
股票叫做券
好
你也知道念券
当然
券
不念卷的
古贝券
有的人会念说龙卷
或龙卷都不对
叫小卷还是卷
就叫龙卷
龙卷
那龙卷呢
那我们是什么时候用呢
预期股价会下跌
预期下跌的时候
我猜它会下跌
对
然后呢
没有股票
那我就先借股票来卖
先卖
后面再买回来
那叫融券
那融券什么时候会增加
什么时候会减少呢
当融券增加的时候
那代表投资人看空
看坏嘛
他认为这档股票应该要下跌
结果这个没有跌
那这个他就去农券来放空它
那农券减少呢
就投资人认为说怎么样
他还会涨上去
好 要回补了
随便讲的回补
对 农券就会减少
那农券余额呢
就是指每天收盘呢
农券卖出
那还没有还
我还是继续看空
对 还没有
对对对
好 那农券维持率呢
他就用农券蛋保品
加农券保证金
处理融券制市值
有点难
没关系
这根本不用记
不用记
反正等你维持不了
券商会通知
券商会call你
哎呀
融券也会断头哦
各位
对
这个不用担心了
那我们现在教这个
融券的条件
谁可以做这个做空呢
谁可以做融券呢
像第一个
我儿子啊
对
我儿子今年要考大学
这个学策了
18岁
对
可是他早就开好户了
所以我都拿他的戶頭
例如說我都戶頭裡面放一筆錢
我就跟他講 兒子啊
我們現在可以來去抽籤
因為最近很多抽籤都還不錯啦
所以他就拿押稅錢去抽的
他可以抽籤 但他不能放空股票
因為放空也是一種融資融券
就信用戶喔
放空有條件啦
年滿20歲才能空
才能开信用户啦
才能开信用户的
那第二个呢
开户要满三个月
第三呢
成交超过十次
那你要做五十万的话
你额度要做到二十五万
那自备呢
要九成资金哦
融券的自备金比较高
融资呢
很多都四成而已
四成就好了
融券要九成哦
借钱给你简单
借股票给你困难
意思是这样
因为融券赔起来很恐怖啦
对啦
上涨无上限
对啊 融资顶都把那个融资金额赔掉而已
融券也可以赔到三倍四倍五倍的哦
对 很恐怖的哦
好 那融券卖出呢我们叫做券卖
那买回呢叫券买
那假如是没有持股的话
当天就不能券卖券买
所以当天买回来呢
我们就要改成资买回来好 等一下会详细帮大家讲不然大家现在有點頭昏好 那放空需要有這個借券費是借券費喔借券費它是萬分之八
好
那通常每個人都要付啦
對
除非你是一個超級超級的大咖啦
像小哥就付的可能比你少
我們有
有些券商是不用付
不用付喔
有些券商是一定要付
是
他說你在大咖我們也是收
好 那不跟他了
但是他可能券比較多
可能券比較多
像元大一定要付
對 元大很硬
元大很硬 元大超硬
但是也不一定他的券就比較多說真的
其實有些小券商的券還蠻多的
好 那我們來看農券成本
那農券賣出至少要付9成
還要付農券費
那假如這重點
若所屬券商未來融資不夠
就得付標借費
好 這個要講白話一點
因為這個標借費有時候很貴
你知道嗎 我最最討厭的就是付標借費
你知道標借費是怎樣
是怎樣 舉例來說
這也是很多投資人跟我有一樣的心情
我們要特別講一下
就來講 禮拜一某一檔股票
就名字講出來
不一定 隨便講一檔
假设礼拜一的宏达店好了
假设宏达店锁涨停
对
我放空它
一锁涨停
感觉好像筹码没有很好
锁涨停的都隔日冲
很多人礼拜二一早
就去空宏达店
就宏达店当天是有券的
为什么
因为礼拜一买的人都是融资
融资买进
就会相对应有融券会卖出
禮拜一这个融资买很多宏达电
结果禮拜二宏达电一早上涨
这些融资纷纷的下车
获利了结
那结果上涨之后
我们去融券放空
也还好啦
融券放空可能就留仓留一天
好 留了看看会不会倒通
结果隔天一早
券商就通知你了
小哥这档券不够了
我说我明明就昨天才空而已
怎么劝就不够了
他说因为昨天融资下车了
那这个叫做标借费
所以你已经空了
他还是会叫你付标借费吗
对
没有武德耶
我已经空在先啦
我明明空的时候有劝啊
对呀
可是你空的时候有劝人家融资下车啦
对
所以你就得付标借费
好这很麻烦哦
有的标借费很贵耶
每天surprise你知道嗎
surprise驚嚇 不是驚喜啊
每天跟你講說 哇 今天標説費3%
日融 日息3%
日融3% 很恐怖喔 3% 4% 很恐怖喔
所以這一定要記得
那一年中呢 戶賓很麻煩
一年中除息錢跟股東會會強制回補
所以這時候可能用期貨來放空
也許會方便一點 不用回補
有的除息還除息四次
對啊 台積電
一年補五次 你知道嗎
所以有時候真的很不喜歡農券
寧願用各股期來做
期貨可能比現股好做
對 好
那農券呢
農券賣出會不會被追繳
我跟你講會的喔
會追繳的喔 那我們來看
大概是多少會不會追繳
假設你放空100塊錢
大概漲46%追角
真的 嘎空嘎到大飆股
你去放空 結果他是飆股
對 你說46%很快嗎
非常快
你去空到一個那個五根漲停的立馬追角
所以當龍券被追角的時候
大部分都是非常痛的時候
所以跟各位講
你做龍券
也有被追角的可能
對 會被追角
所以你做龍券
我們還是跟各位講
你的停損要快一點
是
因為龍券賠起來
其實比龍資還恐怖
對
因為這種標股
它一標
哇 那標速度很快
連續兩三根漲停
之前軋空最有名的
就是宏達電了
才漲兩根
就迫不及待一堆放空
但它漲了好多好多根
因為大家都看他沒有
對啦
結果人家發現
最近蠻厲害的
好 接下來跟各位講
那融券跟融資我們在手機上要怎麼做呢
這是一個手機的畫面喔
好 那我們舉這個最近一檔
美德醫療 美德醫從高檔70塊
78 一路跌到了剩下15塊
那美德醫我每次都會看一個新聞
我都注意看一下 哇
疫情產生了 疫情一產生
這個立馬怎麼樣 每個一個就拉長頂
他拉了幾天之後 我就找機會做什麼事情呢
找機會 融券
好 按融券
賣出
券賣
融券賣出
那假如當天呢
當天這個有殺下來
中錯
我就可以部分回補一點
我就用融資
然後買進
這個是當天交易喔
當天交易
那有時候當天沒有回補
沒關係
你隔天要補的話
那你要記得按
融券買進
隔天就是用融券買進的
這個真的要記得
有時候我也會忘記
當天的話
券賣你想當天回補就是資買
然後隔天的話就是
券買就好啦
那美德意它是屬於第二股
第二股呢
其实你这个
你有没有改无所谓
很多人不知道
我不知道
第二股为什么没有无所谓
龙却买
龙却卖出
龙却卖进
你假如没有改的话
无所谓
为什么
因为第二股的交易税
它就千分之一
可是一般股票
你龙却卖
龙却卖
交易税是千分之三
所以一般股票我们都建议一般股票 假如可以現股当冲的假如你今天是融券卖融资买的你记得打电话给营业员哦
你刚才说
麻烦帮我改成现股当冲
要记得打这种电话哦
差很多哦
他那个交易税从千分之三
就降到千分之一点五哦
差非常多的
所以当天买卖最好
打电话给交易员
营业员
说我是个就是现股当冲
对
你就帮我改现股当冲
因为资券冲的交易税比较贵
因为现股当冲
你可以买多现股当冲
你也可以放空现股当冲
也可以
对
了解了
一个小秘诀
省交易税
好
那这个龙券的股票呢
通常我们都借什么股票要券卖呢
对
那我跟各位讲一下
来抓一下可以放空的话
可是我已经快被前面
这些哩哩哩吓到了
对
好麻煩喔
又可能會被追繳保證金
然後我的保證金要壓九成
隨時隨地還遇到回補的問題
這樣我為什麼還要空
因為有很多股票
它從高檔跌下來
那獲利是很驚人的喔
像今年啊
今年我有一些獲利
都是從剛剛那檔股票來的
每得一
如果選對股票跌幅很快喔
刷刷刷
然后像赵华这种就是
你凭什么
喜欢看不顺眼的人
看不顺眼去空最危险
是啊
那我们刚刚讲的美德一
其实我们不是看他不顺眼
我们是看到底牌你知道吗
因为美德一在新加坡有挂牌
对 他有母公司
所以我每次要去放空他的时候
我都会先看一下
新加坡剩多少錢
先去問候人家媽媽
對
她媽媽
也是她的本體
本體剩7塊
台灣可以賣15塊
15塊加點空一下
意思是放空要有邏輯
我如果看她不順
我要找到邏輯
不是單純情緒
是她有很多的條件
如果符合
基本面可能又覺得
你覺得是不如預期的
那就可以考慮了
放空最害怕看他不爽
只是单纯情绪就不行
所以我们通常建议放空股票
我们要找高档
但是很重要出货
主力筹码松动
主力跑掉了
所以第一个什么叫高档
第一个乖离年限至少超过30%
这个乖离每次大家都觉得痛苦
到底哪边可以查乖离率呢
這個你也可以用簡單的數學算一下
你說用目測嗎
目測
假設年限在100塊
是
大概在130塊以上
那就是乖離年限超過30%
那多得很耶
在目前為止蠻多的
第二個呢
主力持續性的大賣
產物持續性的大買
這個大賣大買有沒有定義
我們可以從線來看
用看著可以 目測就可以了
那幾保戶數呢
大幅的增加
也就是散戶持續大買
那這些呢 我們來看一下
這些呢 來看一下
今年呢 誰符合
我也是從這裡面呢
賺了蠻多錢的一檔股票
叫做2611的
自信
不可自信
那自信呢 各位你還記得六月份的時候
噴了一波嗎 對
到底人家26啊
26开头
那时候26开头
只要26
那自信涨到这个三四十块的时候
公司派纷纷申报转让
你看你就不可自信了嘛
是不是
我公司还不可自信
天啊我们公司
怎么这么好
怎么涨到这么高
每个人都来买啊
那谁买呢
我们来看一下
这个散户
在这一段
散户拼命的买进
那主力在这一段
拼命的到貨
那吉保戶戶在這裡呢
拼命的增加
所以呢
在這個位置啊
各位記得一件事情
這個山的左邊
什麼叫山的左邊呢
各位有沒有看到
自信山
它就出現了
山的左邊
能不要空就不要空
但是很多人在山的左邊拼命空
因為就覺得你長得不合理
不合理
反而在山的右邊都沒空
所以其實自信呢
我賺最多的是右邊這一段
因為左邊這一段說真的
來不及上車
太快了
每天漲停
連續五根漲停
哇 漲停漲停
來不及上
那我要怎麼樣抓到那個翻轉點呢
你說很多人來不及空
因為說實話
如果以技術線型來說
很多人會破月線空
甚至破季線空
早就跌一大段了
所以這麼一大段
當然大家不想空啦
覺得已經跌完了
好
那我們都跟這個全說
第一個 只要一個月內沒再創高
一個月內沒再創高
那代表說月線就準備要下彎了
因為那代表扣底時快到高點了
所以一個月內沒再創高
就準備空它
要等一個月喔
好久耶
不會啊
22個交易日
等一個月之後
它還會有反彈
那又記得你在反彈的時候空腳了
反彈不能過高嘛 對不對
反彈過高那就創高了
那就創新高了
所以反彈過高你就要停損了
那最好再搭配啊
這聲暴轉浪啊
主力大賣啊 那就很好了
好 那自信呢 我在這一段
哇 這個爽賺
好 這是第一檔
那第二個呢 一定很多人問說
那最近有沒有人跟他長得有點像的
这一档其实涨上了横盘整理很久
也没挂点
那这档是171的永光
还记得吗
记得
这个自信是跟谁冲的呢
跟一堆散装嘛
那永光跟谁冲的呢
就跟他的大哥中华画
就画公骨
三皇啊
画公骨嘛
那各位有没有看到
这个永光呢新高雄也一个月没来了對 而且它還不算大跌喔是緩跌喔還沒有喔 對因為我現在跟你講
躺在地上的你也沒什麼興趣
當然啦 人家都躺在地上還披他
你當然喜歡在山上的嘛
至少山腰的
離山上還不會很遠
對
那第二個主力最近也持續性的大賣
那散戶持續性的大賣
買進 終於便宜啦
就一直買它
對 那幾保護數呢
這個增加
所以这看起来就有点机会了
那这个我们要找券支笔低的
什么叫券支笔我们待会教了
那找券支笔低的比较安全
这种感觉就是你飙涨的时候我追不上你
你崩跌的时候我总要踢个两脚
对 没错
你漂亮的时候来不及追
不是这么说的
那這個17開頭的
他們就在前兩三個月很紅啊
好 都同一條船上的
對 那時候大盤殺的時候
都專門拉17的
那最近呢17的
最近三黃也是一個月怎麼樣
沒創新高
也是一個月沒創新高
那主力呢 有看到
這主力從往真的蠻醜的
真的耶
那傻貿最近也進來買了
對
所以各位這一檔呢
你可以觀察看看
好
那你记得一件事情
只要一创高
就只能停损了
一创高你要记得停损
别闹了
这种股票腰起来你也会吓死
对 好
好 那我们刚刚讲的东西
很重要的就是这个参数
叫做劝资比
那劝资比是劝余额除以
融资余额乘100%
那劝资比越高的
那就代表资党股票被大量放空
是 好
那券子比高有兩個含有一個會嘎
一個會殺 待會再教你看
券子比高還會殺嗎
會喔 像剛剛講的美德一
他的券子比都很高
很高那不代表空軍大獲全勝了嗎
美德一其實是空軍大獲全勝
好 那券子比到底多少才叫高呢
30% 30%就很高了
好 券子比其實很容易查啦
你Google每一檔的勸資比
其實很容易查
甚至前一陣子有60% 70%勸資比
我還看過90%勸資比
有的
超誇張
來看一下有的
這個厲害
來看第一檔
3701大眾控
大眾控這個是腰啊
腰啊
勸資比多少
96.5%
是
這就全世界都看你不順眼啊
我每天都在看那個大眾控的標誡費
哇塞 這些人放空是怎樣
錢那麼多 每天付標課費
我就不信你不倒
大眾共捐身比高有兩個因素
第一個是因為長太多了
真的長太多了啦
四五倍以上了
第二個是它的可轉債
它的可轉債 折價20%
折價20%什麼概念呢
你假如拿得到券的話
你可以去套利這中間的20%
好 這個我們之後再交
總之就是一個全部人都看他怎麼還不趕快垮
他快不送
第二個開發金
開發金有什麼好空大?金融股
他不是有併購的題材嗎?
對啊
有人去鎖利
鎖利
有時候是避險
不一樣
那第三名美德一
像恆大
美德一恆大人家就是知道這個行業怎麼樣
在未來會有點問題
炒题材嘛 疫情来 Omicron来了
恒代涨几两天啊
对 题材 而且呢
他们未来的营收可能会
比较没那么好 对啦
没有今年那么好
我昨天去买一盒口罩剩下75块
哎呦 你不要买太便宜的好不好
诶 那个口罩还很好用哦
真的 75块的口罩
所以你就看看这个口罩累果
真的蛮危险的 好
好 那剩下的呢
我们来看剩下最近比较标的
萬泰科
這真的
多標啊
勸支比多少呢
我們來看萬泰科勸支比68
可是像這種的啊
我有時候都會跟觀眾朋友說
你剛才去混進去
轉胎跟漲停反而不是空它
對
那每天所漲停啊
所以呢我們跟妳講啊
這勸支比高的喔
妳一定要再看一個東西叫
月線的斜率
哎呦好
月線斜率萬泰科到了2.5啊
什麼意思啊
它月線的值呢
每天漲2.5
對
哇所以這是標股了
月線1%就是標股了
這到2.5%
好
這非常翹的
所以這樣不要碰它是不是
所以我們都講
月線很陡的
月線往上的
對
卷之比高的
不要去空它
好不要空它
就不會空到腰股囉
反而你可以找機會上車啊
欸
好這個我們等一下聊
好的
所以类似这种股票呢
就是它就容易有
载空行情
好的
非常谢谢小哥
刚刚我们是一个龙券大补铁
因为很多人对于什么是龙券
什么是放空
还没有概念
简单的说就是你看坏它嘛
看坏它你就去借它的股票
先卖掉先换钱
等到它跌下去了
你再便宜的买股票来还给券商
你不就赚了这个价差吗
说起来简单
等你实际运用的时候
它其实有一些限制
今天都一并介绍给你啦
所以呢
记得参考我们的荣耀班
因为荣耀班里面会教你什么呢
它会教你
怎么找到高券资比的股票
它反而是应该来做多
享受别人放空的燃料
这是一个反向思考啦
好
今天非常谢谢小哥哦
小哥来教我们整套的
这个龙券放空的概念
然后也提醒大家啦
因為龍圈放空限制真的比較多
有時候開股東會你要回補
除全息你要回補
你的保證金的層數也是比較高的
你要放九成的保證金
點點點點
那為什麼還要放空
因為大盤在高檔
或者個股在高檔
總會有回落的時候
而且多空雙向你會把握的話
有時候反而保護你的多單
這個也很重要
那希望今天的歌有仇必報
對你的投資有幫助
我們下次再見囉
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜